should artists waste their time in art
school no you shouldn't waste your time
ever I think your question is is it
necessarily a waste of time to go to art
school and I would say it depends very
much on the art school and on what you
do while you're there if you go to art
school and you really work at it like
mad and you devote yourself to it and
you're in the library and you're
studying the great masters and you're
crafting your technique and you're at a
school where that's actually possible
then you can educate yourself and going
to art school can give you an identity
that allows you to investigate that
possibility free from undue social
pressure for some period of time which
is really the case with a an arts degree
or something like that as well so if you
can take advantage of it if you're
disciplined enough and if you can find a
school that isn't completely appallingly
postmodern and and social justice
oriented instead of oriented towards art
then I don't think it has to be a waste
of time but I think there's a high
probability that it will